if Clinton got that upset discussing
Lewinsky
imagine if the Today Show had asked
about the women who told him no joining
us now are Kathleen Willey
and Juanita Broderick author of the new
book you'd better put some ice on that
how I survived being raped by Bill
Clinton it's great to see both of you I
have been thinking about both of you all
day and also Paula Juanita I want to
start with you Bill Clinton did approach
you did he not in 1992 to apologize
crowd yes he did it was in 1991 I was in
Little Rock at a nursing home seminar
someone comes to the door and says I'm
wanted in the hallway I go out and the
man points down around the corner by the
elevator and so I go down there and as I
round the corner there stands Bill
Clinton with two of his Arkansas State
Police guards and he rushes over to me
and he starts this profuse apology and
saying I'm so sorry for what I did I'm a
changed man I'm just not the man I used
to be and even said I'm a family man now
and I just looked at him Laura and I I
was just flabbergasted and I said you go
to hell and I walked off and I could not
believe it and then the nurses that have
were with me followed me out and they
came over to me and they said what did
he want and I told him and then I began
to feel a little bad that I had said
that I kept thinking well maybe he
really meant that maybe he really was
apologized and then what happened you
realize oh yeah and you realize yeah
fast forward that he was running for
president and you were going to perhaps
be an obstacle to that right that's
exactly a week later after he apologized
he announced he was running for
president a week later oh that's really
that's really that's really subtle
that's really subtle kathleen willey you
watch that interview today and I mean
I've got to say I'm always stunned why
am i stunned he has not learned anything
about this experiment which is he's
actually a smart guy so I don't I'm I'm
almost speechless your reaction I was
speechless too I was outraged I could
not believe the words that were coming
out of his mouth and he was so arrogant
and pompous about the whole thing he
actually believed I think he actually
does believe that he didn't do anything
wrong and you know he just blanket
apology I've apologized to everybody in
the world well okay
but he hasn't apologized to the people
that he hurt and the people that he
destroyed the women that he destroyed
he hasn't apologized to me he has not
apologized to Kepala
he apologized in one video but as we see
there was a plan to that it was a
purpose for that and he hasn't
apologized to Leslie or numerous other
women who have come forward and said it
told stories about it he never will he
doesn't get it it's just the way it is
well but he he seems to think that he
ain't mean he handled it well I mean to
watch that interview he he didn't say he
would have done anything differently we
look everyone as everybody makes
mistakes in their lives coulda shoulda
woulda we all do I mean lord knows we
all do but it's II would think 20 years
later you'd say you know I wish I could
turn back the clock and you know show
better judgment but I mean I do that
like 50 times a day like why did I do
that but it's just a little it's a
little strange
Allison Camerata on CNN offered somewhat
tepid critique of this performance let's
watch there could have been a more
practiced answer or one that I think
alluded to the ignition that the rules
have changed in the past 20 years
obviously the rules were different and
that he would have done something
perhaps differently today or that he
would say something differently about it
today he could have had a more practiced
answer juanita I mean like yeah Oh Mikey
could have also not portrayed himself as
a victim how does he become the victim
in all
I know I saw this decrepid angry old man
who is trying to play the victim card
the same man who forty years ago raped
me yeah it was it was disgusting
well Kathleen it would have been really
amazing I'm I'm shocked that Melvin
asked these questions but it would have
been too it would have been really
amazing things about asked about Juanita
you and the others but he focused on
Monica Lewinsky because I guess that was
the impeachment but I mean II did enjoy
Lockhart let's just play this quickly I
want Kathleen to react to this Joe
Lockhart former White House press
secretary said this today let's watch it
highlights the vast difference between
what it was like 20 years ago and today
I think in that interview he succumbed
to being the victim and feeling
victimized victimized Kathleen
apologized he left the White House 16
million dollars in debt well let me tell
you about what being a dentist like and
not being able to get a meaningful job
after being through all of that and he
hired all this went all these women to
work in his office and he has a sexual
partner sexual harassment policy in
Arkansas yeah well we probably had a lot
of women around so he could you know
assault them and you know there's no
different sexual harassment policy in
there in Arkansas that never was one
there never was one Kathleen Kathleen if
he called you today and said look I know
I came off bad on that interview but I'm
really sorry for causing you pain I'm
sorry for what I did would you accept
his apology no I tell him the same thing
that Juanita told them Juanita same
question if you called you today I mean
look everybody can be redeemed right
we're supposed to believe in Redemption
all of us
I mean if most of us do I don't believe
yeah I don't believe there's any
redemption in regard to Bill and Hillary
Clinton I do not believe that and
I would probably tell him the same thing
again today all right thank you both I
mean I suffered yeah yeah well thank you
both for being here tonight and